good evening good evening and welcome to
the Barnes & Noble Upper East Side we
thank all you guys for coming out here
on a rainy night here in New York City
before we begin tonight's program if you
could all just please double check your
cell phones and make sure that they are
turned off we would appreciate that
so immediately following our discussion
and reading we're going to open it up to
you guys there's some questions and
answers and then immediately following
that we will begin our signing we're
just going to pull the table out here
we're going to have Gina situated up on
the stage and if you would line up here
that's where the signing line would
start we have books available for
purchase right outside and I'm sure Gina
would be more than happy to sign them
for you she is a medical reporter for
the New York Times and author of the
book flu and we are delighted to welcome
Gina kalana to the Barnes & Noble Upper
East Side she is here tonight to discuss
her brand new book mercies in disguise
story of hope a family's genetic destiny
and the science that rescued them ladies
and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming Gina Colada
[Applause]
okay thank you all for coming out
tonight on this cold rainy night I
really appreciate it I I'm going to have
a little bit of trouble talking about
this book because it's because it's like
it's a story and every chapter builds on
the one before it and it's a medical
mystery and what I don't want to do is
to give away the story because people
who've read I actually find myself
getting drawn into it when I read it
again
so I don't want the rest of you to feel
ya know make you feel like I know what's
going to happen I know this story but I
do want to say that this has been
working on this book has been just an
incredibly moving experience I had no
idea with what this story was going to
be when I first started it
I met the baxley family who are the
center of the book and they they just
opened themselves I don't don't
understand why but they did they told me
their story in their story was amazing
that you I can tell you that they
discovered that they have had a genetic
disease and their family they traced it
back five generations and that but no
one could figure out what it was I mean
nobody they went everywhere they even
went to the National Institutes of
Health they went to major medical
centers no one knew what it was they
figured it out and the way they figured
it out I had a friend who read the book
and said his diction right Gina and I
said no it's not every single thing here
is true and the way they figured it out
seems almost like it was a revelation
and they were right they were right
about what it was and then they were
faced with another decision and the
other decision was there you know what
the disease is
it's caused by a mutant gene if you get
this mutated gene you are going to get
this disease 100% certainty and if you
get the disease unless something happens
soon with the research
you're going to have a difficult course
ending in debt and it's going to
probably strike you in middle age so
they all have each person had to decide
who is at risk do you want to know if
you have it if your mother or father had
the disease you a 50% chance of having
that team if you want to know and if you
do know what do you do about children
what you do about marriage how do you
live your life and how do you live your
life if you don't know and how do you
live your life if you do know so I
wanted we're really lucky tonight
because Amanda kolinsky who is the
subject of the second half of the book
is here with us tonight she came from
South Carolina to be here and I wanted
to introduce her by reading part of the
introduction to the book Oh actually I
want to want to read you the little
quotes - one of them I found my husband
was watching one of his crazy movies on
TV and it is this quote though from Mark
Twain I don't know where this kaleipus
quote showed up because he watches you
know I I don't to say what I call them
but they're they're movies that I would
never watch and I almost said this bill
too embarrassing to say that here anyway
what the Mark Twain quote was the two
most important days of your life of the
day you were born and the day you find
out why and the second quote is from
Amanda's mom Kathy told me to listen to
this song blessings by a woman named
Laura and Laura's husband that Kathy had
told me that he was dying of lung cancer
and she wrote this this song and the
refrain was what are the trials of this
life the rain the storms the hardest
nights are Your mercies in disguise and
that's where the title of the book comes
from - and what was interesting was what
was inspiring about the baxley family is
they took something that could destroy a
family and they made it they had made in
a way they came together over and
they became stronger and they didn't let
it destroy them as her brother as her
uncle Mike at one point said they've
been they didn't wanted to sit there and
be slain by this disease so I'm going to
read you a little bit of introduction
that Amanda's going to tell you a little
bit and once again I trying my best not
to tell you what the story is the two
people Amanda packs Lea loves the most
begged her not to be tested at least not
now please her mother pleaded your dad
is so sick we are hurting so much
already
her boyfriend implored her not to invite
news that could cast such a long and
dark shadow over their future you don't
know what it will do to you he warned
but she had always been so stubborn so
sure what she wanted so able to push
past trepidation and she was driven by
the impossible expectations of what this
day would bring
she had to know her future in order to
control it if she had the mutated gene a
forecast of a horrifying and fatal
illness one without treatment or cure
passed down her family from generation
to generation she vowed it would stop
with her so today with her mother and
her boyfriend beside her for support
Amanda sits across from her therapist
now at 26 years old she is facing a
dilemma that seemed to reach beyond her
young adulthood into the ageless realm
of the surreal
which life would be the one in which the
years stretch out outward boundlessly
were the one with the future twists into
a discernable ghastly shape
Amanda glances around the room the
office is as it ever was cozy with a
fireplace across from a loveseat and a
couple of chairs she has been here many
times before but now it is another world
Amanda's fate resides in the results of
a blood test will reveal whether she
possesses a single mutated gene one that
is contorted to face of so many four
family members
the results are with the doctor in
California who ordered the tests in a
few minutes the phone will ring and the
doctor on the other side of the country
will open the envelope and tell her over
speakerphone the faithful news and with
that I want to introduce Amanda kolinsky
who will tell you a little bit about her
side of the story hey everybody so I
tend to get a little emotional when I
talk about this so I have to read just
bear with me I'm sure at this point
you're thinking to yourself why why in
the world would you choose to have a
genetic test whose outcome foretells
your fate why would you want to know
whether or not your death will be as
slow as painful as scary as humiliating
as your father's your grandfather's or
your uncles and if you did make this
decision to know your fate what would
you do with the answer that you were
given well you know I could give you my
answers to these questions I could talk
about the whys in the house but then why
would you need or want to read the book
and believe me you want to read it when
I was first approached by Gina about the
possibility of a book I have to be
honest with you my first reaction was
huh why would you want to write a book
about us but my second reaction was
absolutely let's do it and who's going
to play me in the movie at the time I
didn't realize how many doors would be
open for not only myself but for my
family this book and the incredibly
talented author behind it has given me
the chance to tell my story
and my family's story to the world it's
given us the chance to spread awareness
about our one and 100,000,000 disease
which will in turn help to find a cure
it's given us the chance to be open and
honest about our personal struggles with
this disease and by being so open we
have grown as a family and have come
together as a stronger more united front
against this disease it's given us the
chance to spread the message of hope to
those who really need to hear it and
it's given me the opportunity to reflect
on the magnitude of love for my husband
or might the magnitude of love my
husband has for me and it's helped me to
fully realize the depth of love the love
that I have for him it's given me the
chance to leave behind my story for my
children when I'm no longer here to tell
it I hope that my children will be proud
when they read it I hope they will feel
my love emanating from the pages I hope
that they will know I did everything I
could for them and that I will always
love them it's given me validation that
I'm worth writing about
and that this disease does not define me
[Music]
ultimately I hope that this book gives
me more of a chance to grow old with my
husband and see the fruits of our
Labor's our beautiful three kids Thank
You Gino for giving me this hope at the
beginning of the book there's a quote of
Mark Twain's when she read the two most
important days in your life of the day
you are born and the day you find out
why I truly believe that this this book
this story this life this fight this is
my why so thank you we would be happy to
take questions
[Music]
yes
[Laughter]
oh my gosh sorry hi
I have there are people I never met in
person sorry she's one of us
[Music]
what a surprise me since the book came
out and people have started asking me
questions I guess what surprised me most
is that the questions I've asked have
always been asked I've always been what
about the test the gene test and to me
this story is so much more about what
gives a family strength what gives them
hope how do they deal with what could a
tragedy that could destroy people that
that to me is the real story if you say
would you take a gene test some people
are just very cavalier oh yeah I'd want
to know well you know you have to live
it to know whether I have no idea what I
would do I'd have to be in that
situation but I was deeply moved by the
by Amanda and her family and the way
that they learned to deal with the best
situation and find hope when you might
think there would be none yes
[Music]
they come
so I hear many stories many science
stories why did I choose this one and
why did I think it was a book well
actually I don't think in terms of books
I think in terms of newspaper stories
and they're very self-contained and they
have one question and one central point
and you make that point and you're out
of there and this story the one central
point was testing you know what you
should you be tested and then what do
you do and I have an age and two things
in terms of books she said hey Gina this
could be a book and I actually had no
idea what it really was and she has she
also doesn't make us write these long
long proposals because I didn't know it
was coming in this book this book was me
I had no idea what this story was and I
and when I first met Amanda I started
realized and her family I started to
realize what it was but it actually took
the whole two years that I was working I
had to fully appreciate this story there
was no way I could ever have guessed
what this was really all about I was
lucky because I met an amazing family
really amazing family and you had a
question okay yes
[Music]
our immigration
Carthage acknowledged
you're a traitor
showing her
[Music]
so the question was she has traumatic
brain injury and she asked him and if
she has been hospitalized it's different
it's a different kind of condition
because nothing happens until it happens
and in but any you know any I think that
the story is universal in a way it could
be it could apply to traumatic brain
injuries or anything it's like how do
you deal with a bad situation and how do
you find hope and strength when you have
a condition that might make people want
to just give up yes it's a blood test
yeah and one thing how do you test for
gene it's a blood test once they know a
mutation is there they don't have to
look at all the DNA they have these
little probes that can zoom in and say
yes or no there's there's the gene the
mutated gene or not so that's what they
do it's actually relatively simple
though it takes a long time to get the
results back on the line how long did
you wait Amanda eight weeks yeah a long
time when you're sitting there wondering
what's your result once you've decided
to know and then you have to wait eight
weeks it's not easy you want to tell
them what you did during those eight
weeks so I went on a volunteer trip to
Africa
I traveled by myself and stayed in a
hostel and I was a nurse for six weeks
so that took my mind off of it
[Music]
any other question yes
how did I come to this story in
particular well there's a Gaius Duke
he's a researcher and he likes to get
publicity and if he has something where
he's like a co-author or something he
he's the kind of guy to call up they
have an interesting story coming out so
he called me and said there's an
interesting paper coming out he happened
to be a co-author and it was coming out
in a medical journal and it would make
good story because of the ethics angle
and I said well the only reason that
this could work for me is if the person
who is the subject of this story would
be willing to be identified and talk to
me and he says I can't give you her name
because of the HIPPA regulations but if
you go through her private doctor I
think she wants to talk so I went
through her private doctor who put me in
touch with Amanda and it was a good
story and it was on page one but like I
said it was like a a one subject story
you know it didn't didn't tell the whole
family dynamic it was like one little
one
what made one point and it made a point
that readers really they were they
commented on it and people had very
different reactions and it it was a
story that got a lot of readers but it
wasn't the book it was just a piece of
the book
yes Tim and add beautiful
the fact was
on the slide how to prepare people for
the news and I wonder what your how you
describe that experiences feelings are
about many professionals at this point
have a good looking back I actually have
a very positive feeling about medical
professionals and about the medical
professionals that dealt with me during
that time of my life yeah there's always
you know bad stories but mine was good
they they were very open and honest
about the fact that they didn't know
very much but they were very willing to
point me in the direction of where I
needed to go so I had a very positive
experience and I would not actually
change the thing about it yes how many
people have the disease in the world in
the United States
that's for you Amanda daddy actually
there's a bigger category but they're
all very closely related do you want the
bigger category or the small in the
bigger one
[Music]
350 cases per year in the u.s. pretty
rare and that's just prion disease in
general
[Music]
the 10 to 15 percent of those are
genetic now there was new cases not
people living with it people newly
diagnosed and not everybody as Amanda's
family stories would will attest who has
one of these diseases gets a correct
diagnosis because with Amanda's
grandfather they kept saying it's a
combination of Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's it clearly wasn't in fact
practically right before he died he
nailed the final question on Jeopardy
and you're not going to do that if you
have you're dying of Alzheimer's disease
yeah yeah I think yet you had your hand
up earlier
[Music]
so I read it in about an area repeat the
question okay so what was it like to
read the book in the final form I read
it in about a day and it was in all
honesty it was like reliving it so it
was very very emotional for me but it
was incredible it is absolutely
incredible
it is it is so true in fact and it's so
true and the emotion that surrounds it
so it was it was hard but it was so
worth it
and then you had a question as well
[Music]
here
have there been major medical advances
any medical advances I can Debbi
probably knows more than I do I was at
there at the meeting of the CJD
Foundation which is a foundation like
the Arthritis Foundation or diabetes
where they they support people who have
the disease and they also sponsor
research and they always need money
because there's never enough money for
the research and but when I was there I
heard some very interesting really
intriguing ideas but they were very
preliminary not yet something that you
would try to give to a patient but
things might have changed Debbie and
[Music]
[Music]
not
[Music]
minute
[Music]
I
[Music]
yeah and that was interesting she met
she said that I'm well it's been very
incremental but one of the big advances
is that they can test a lot of compounds
at once instead of one at a time which
is important because there had been at
least one situation where they thought
they had something that would work and
then you can wait in that waste you can
spend years which is what they did
before they found out that what we
thought was working didn't make any
difference at all so you don't want to
go down a path like that if you don't
have to obviously other questions we'll
probably take one more and then
[Music]
[Music]
if you guys didn't hear she thinks
amanda is the most inspirational person
she has ever met and I have to second
that thank you all so much